i want to say congrats on the first
episode i just watched it and uh
um i think it's really good i think kids
are really gonna it's aimed at kids and
i think kids are gonna love it do you
like do you watch a lot of animated
stuff i watch uh why uh i've watched a
fair amount of animated stuff for work
and um but i think it does you know not
uh it does what it needs to do and i'm
i'm a fan of having kids getting
introduced to star trek at an early i
mean it's never been done before i think
it's a very smart idea so what do you
mean it does what it needs to do are you
because it's introducing a a younger
audience to star trek yes exactly right
and you think that it's successful in
that regard these first 100
wonderful i'm happy to hear you say that
uh so
something that i think is kind of funny
or amusing at least is you make a
voyager and you're dealing with a
hologram and now you are the hologram
that's right
bob picardo's got having a good laugh
i found that i found that amusing um so
what has been your favorite part
actually of making the show in the
episodes um and the scripts you've been
reading
i think the uh the rather singular
experience of being in a recording booth
all by myself
uh they're on zoom
and i've got my headset i've always
loved it i don't know why it's visceral
to me um
i love uh that dynamic just between
myself my voice and the page
um
it's very very liberating for some
reason
uh it has to be i think if you're going
to be an effective voice actor so i i
very much enjoy the experience
how has it been actually because
obviously
you've played this character for many
years you know this character inside and
out how has it been
working in terms of you're reading a
script and you think to yourself maybe
we want to do it a different way or how
has it been that sort of you know
dynamic back and forth with the
directors and writers it's been great
and i get to do it all different kinds
of ways and i do
um
that is the one great plus uh voice
acting has over live action because even
though you can do a second take and
sometimes a third or fourth and a fifth
in live action it's an elaborate to do i
mean the camera's got to reset and you
got to get the angle you get the lights
but in this case i can go quickly right
away again i can i can immediately grasp
what it is i wanted to do and do it and
so it's great
i definitely have to ask you you were
the first female captain in star trek
which i think is awesome uh what does it
actually mean to you uh being the first
female uh star trek captain
you know it means
it means that i have to be responsible
for playing someone who is
truly
uh
significant
uh
in a
uh deeply resonant way
um that's there's an accountability here
um
and i've understood that about janeway
and i hope that i have stepped up to the
plate
successfully in that regard because it
matters to me
it also matters to a lot of women out
there and a lot of a lot of people um
was there any was there any hesitation
on revisiting janeway in the role or was
it like did you have to be convinced or
when you heard the idea were you like oh
i want to do this
there was hesitation in so far as as i
just said to you she is so important to
me
and that chapter was so vivid
and so hard
and so worthwhile
and so singular
to call it back again i thought might be
too
uh
taxing but the opposite has happened
it's been quite freeing
it's been elevating
it's been
perfectly enjoyable
and i'm i'm having really the time of my
life doing it
uh when you think back on the making of
voyager uh i'm sure you don't miss the
long hours and all that but are there
what are the things you you miss about
playing the role on almost a daily basis
if anything i miss the exercise of that
particular kind of discipline
which is a very uh reinforcing
discipline
for an actor to experience most actors
don't get the shot
seven years 16 18 hours a day raising
two small children by herself
i learned what i'm capable of doing
and i was very pleased to be able to
deepen that and to heighten that as the
case may be
on that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say congrats on the series i
hope it's a big hit for you guys
thank you for giving me your time thank
you take care thanks